hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma now I can hear
the monster in the other room I had to
take a break after the end of the
episode I have to take a little walk
away from it but I'm back into it and I
am a little better off because I think I
found a power pack oh hey okay
so it's important I don't know what's
important but are you still here
should I be concerned about all the
wibbly-wobbly okay so apparently it's
important that I stop the WoW and get
the virus that's pretty much everything
that I've learned up to this point
oh god damn I must really suck to have
your brain explode like that a little
too much black box in their lives uh
excuse me sir
excuse me buddy I'm just gonna step in
here this morning
uh-huh the Ark team went out a couple of
days ago but I see no reason to suspect
them playing upon his death the climate
can't be operated from the abyss so
there was scheduled to travel the
climate returned with only a lifeless
body of alpha member yo.hannes Rose no
traces of the ark team
Cameron Eames lansky all studying the
body inside containment I'll follow up
with whatever they find
okay so I'm pretty sure that the WoW is
stopping something from happening down
in the abyss
the way I was thinking more aggressive
pushing systems demand limits ironically
the dead dr. Johan Ross would be the
perfect person to ask why the WoW is
making such a big buzz about his passing
after all the WoW isn't supposed to love
anything definitely not to warn people
the system overload affects the staff
considerably headaches or sleep or more
it is stress and it seems to be getting
worse I could use some advice if you can
get through your brains gone explode
Elan de asks your brains gonna lose the
scarf looks like they're about to
explode an analyst is deprovision he
walks around with nosebleeds and the
rest keep what he stains of blood from
their eyes to keep them from overflowing
as to do the well trying to free Ross
somehow for sure at this point I
wouldn't be surprised that the body just
got up and left
rally-ho burr our dispatcher has been
snooping around asking questions she
shouldn't she says she's going down into
the abyss to find alpha let's send those
along
what's that slapping sound please be
Robo Burgess okay man twice everyone's
heads exploding pushed on my floodlight
until I heard screaming over the
short-range radio carried on as a hurry
closer or something big and almost
guttering - whoa saving town more
specifically saving Ross as I heard
Espinoza's colleagues getting massacred
what the hell's going on down there why
am i walking willingly into that with
some loss rah look Ross made it back to
town is able to continue his work at
alpha no he's dead to avoid further
disturbances I've decided to report the
evacuation as a complete failure hoping
it will stop theta from attempting
another one stop fated from attempting
another one
Claudia Eames the manager of Omicron has
already ordered the climber to stay at
the plateau for now my report on the
savage Wildlife's card scared everyone
enough to even stop Waldeck and Darby oh
boy
there's Wow controlled wildlife down
there tearing people into that's really
good
Carthage marks rang is dead Ross is dead
Dahl is dead oh man
Oh with the brain exploding why is that
a thing I mean I know why it's a thing
the WoW is obviously trying to do
something but apparently when Ross died
and Ross may have been the creator of
the world I'm gonna call it the wall
from now on just cuz it's a little more
amazing what was that what is that why
is that I didn't mean to do that
whoa whoa okay I thought that was a
thing that really sounded like it was a
thing I'm not fooling anybody right I
really thought that was a thing okay
anyway we're good
I got a Power Core now I need structure
gel and something else I think chip from
a computer I don't know where to find a
chip from a computer but I imagine I
have to pull it out of something
unwillingly uh I mean there was that
dude on the ground with the computer
face in the room with the screamy lady
I'm gonna call her the librarian cuz she
do not like noise okay no one else is in
here right good wait was this on before
I don't know if this is on an unusually
sedated orange roughy found hovering
outside Omicron station they had a
remarkable bone growth that seemed in oh
it's a goddamn I think that's a fish
start banging on the glass blood itself
to death Darby and Waldeck identified it
as what was sabotaging the Llumar probe
about 900 meters down a rudder fish so
the WoW is using fish to sabotage
something for some reason dead man found
on the clowner is real han Ross okay I
already knew that all right no foreign
containment but debate that beyond this
point OB Toby
I mean haba dead body inside of my body
is that a foreign contaminant himmat
well alrighty then hello this looks fun
although the monstrosity is happening
here I mean apparently this station was
the site of a lot of experimentation on
what the Wow was doing which is good and
all oh oh no that's not you
whose Oh
oh okay so this thing grows real good
like structure gel test formula at theta
split okay structure gel has been
charged and actually keeps going for a
while even when removed from the power
source if applied to circuits it seems
to help out with connectivity not only
connectivity but functionality gel can
make simple machinery work and act more
efficiently what is this wonder gel when
applied to something more complicated
caused the gel to act as a cancer upon
the host eventually ruining it ruining
it I get i I know I know I'm supposed to
stop the WoW for some reason
apply gel to dead mouse gel caused the
mouse to appear alive who's put into the
same habitat as living Mouse the
reanimated Mouse with a pathetic while
the living one seems stress after 15
minutes reanimated Mouse attacked and
killed the living Mouse half an hour
later the reanimated Mouse stopped
moving the course was solid as gel had
hardened within it reanimated another
Mouse with structure gel this time it
was done with uncalibrated gel is
produced by Eames the results were
impressive I get it I get it the thing
appears catatonic but it's more of a
sleepwalker to avoid the thing hardening
as before electro matting magnets are
used to cause a low electrical current
within the animal this also provide us
with the ability to someone control it
structure gel remains unchanged on a
fundamental level cross-linked gel wow
it's controller Wow the controller this
structure gel okay okay so the WoW is
using the structure gel to cause these
growths and make all the living things
not alive anymore don't do that
okay so I need to find another
controller chip I thought I needed to
find a controller chip anyway oh is that
you making those noises I can't open it
seems to be locked up I mean not that I
blame him but he didn't stop his head
from exploding
know one thing to remove the thingies Oh
what oh oh that's what's in the cell
okay
is that a control chip can't use this
maybe not huh so maybe I can yeah I can
put this down and maybe it'll be able to
fix it fix it
Oh God zing zip Aviv um no maybe I need
to run the program from the computer
hello
oh I get it oh I see so I'm going to
dispense gel onto this bad boy because
that's how I do things
yeah no not come on come on now good
enough huh yeah see good stuff
that must be what all the robo bose
hoods are all about
oh that's well that's creepy
but apparently through the power of
science this now works better could you
hurry okay but first I'm gonna run a
little experiment because there's a
mouse and another one I'm gonna see what
happens when this happens I'm sure this
will be fun
good yeah progress yeah I guess oh my
god oh my god ah that's horrible
oh it's horrible or is it horrible I
don't know mr. life something like it
yeah why why why why
that's weird that's weird okay alright
so I got what I needed and now I can if
I know I need to take it out of here no
I already got it I need to put it back
in here because for some reason okay I
don't know why that was so important
that I needed to do that to open this
thing okay I got a while structure jail
do daddy I'll just put that up my but
great storage up there very spacious so
that one wasn't so bad I imagine it
could still get worse but that one
wasn't as bad as the other one at least
I didn't have to run into the librarian
any day now I got places to be
okay the last thing I need is a control
chip from a computer which I'm mama
which I imagine is downstairs is it high
oh god it's so weird poison the oil I
don't know what you is how do you do
that oh this ain't good
leave me poison the well someone poison
water hole okay so I don't remember how
okay must be down here that's right
there was another door through here
wasn't there I thought I remember there
being but maybe it was blocked off did i
override it I may have to override it
here here we go that's right
override please gotta go to gum drops
now everything is gonna be better I'm
sure down the basement is not the worst
of all the enemies okay oh you still
have your head and your breathing I'm
gonna come to you in just a second but
first time I lock myself in here for a
little bit is that bubble butt Nass not
bubble butt okay what do we got here
Diagnostics ok so that's a little odd
comms am i trying to make straight lines
with the things or am i doing something
else ok so I want that thing to run ok
so Oh bang optics on just in case this
is actually a thing that's important
bang bang
hello how you doing buddy
if I didn't know any better I think he
was screaming
okay Wow all right so let's uh stop that
for a little bit let's see let's have
this one pass through no I need huh okay
so I need these things to pass through
there we go okay got it
sorry buddy I need this okay why is it a
face that doesn't seem like the thing
that I actually needed oh well I'm not
exactly someone to complain about what's
been given to me I don't know what these
means it seems to be mad oh my god is
Bubble Boy oh look a bubble blood over
there is this where bubble butt was made
micron I mean to be honest bubble butt
seemed didn't seem to be infected by the
Wow huh
hey buddy whoa jeez what the hell you're
like fully robot what the hell that's
really weird why is that guy like fully
robot there's another but I could stick
my hand into dang yeah okay I get it
I want to whoa let me let me get now get
this I don't think I needed I haven't
been hurt yet but might as well right
goody goody gumdrops
okay good I forgot that drain power out
of the area maybe that's another crap
you're not thinking of getting up are
you good stay down okay so that did a
thing so now I got a bunch of these I
don't know what this is the heart of
alpha I don't know what alpha is and tau
find alpha take the third gel to alpha
okay seems to be a lot of Illuminatus
stuff alpha doesn't even exist into the
abyss take it to alpha and the abyss so
something is affecting its mind
it's sick alpha needs medicine so alpha
is where the Wow is maybe that's
structure gel another I don't think I
should take it down there hey you heard
me what's happened able to connect
Llumar relay out of range Tao please
respond
this is rally Herber calling from
Omicron please respond Tao the orders a
little out of this one able to connect
Llumar relay out of range
Omicron can you hear us loud and clear
everyone all right you will be as soon
as we make friends with the power suits
I'm sure you'll get used to it
just wanted to check in before we pass
the Lance Burton Lu our pro guys last
words come from you heard that right
don't worry I won't forget you James
rusty are you there
I hear you Herbie what's up here you
need to check-in I have to go do
something I might not be around for a
few days okay rally her relieving the
listening post must be important it's
dress okay no Stacy okay then
apparently she at the listening post had
been having voices in her head I'm
thinking that maybe good taking this
stuff down into the abyss would actually
help the Wow and I'm not sure that's
what I want to do take the virus stop
the Wow why would it tell why would I
have voices in my head telling me to
stop the Wow and yet she had voices in
her head telling her to take structure
gel down to the Wow unless the WoW is
intact of the whoa sorry unless the whoa
hey ah sexy loading time unless the whoa
isn't actually down there see I'm still
confused I I probably shouldn't make
many guesses Jesus
oh you're gonna fall oh my go is that
the librarian am I going the right way I
think so didn't he literally do
someone's upset someone needs some
aromatherapy someone needs to not be a
horrible robot baby the boop boop boo
boo bank
oh whoa come on why you gotta be like
you know hey lock the door hey notice
piss off another one of us monsters we
have everything we need right yeah let's
get to work
yeah let's get to work working on this
dead body do I got a man I got a manual
we do oh I gotta shove the oh oh
this is crazy don't worry it'll work why
would it work shove this up your butt
hmm okay yeah it just seems like some
sort of satanic ritual going on with the
electricity weird skull and make sure it
all peak at a structure gel connecting
all the parts all right try activating
the seat from the terminology I don't
want it
I don't want it I don't want to do this
this seems weird
this seems wrong why does he feel so
good okay cortex activity free try that
observe from the book of James you know
is held in theory of relativity he
remembers everything go having about
baby can't believe we're doing this it
will be fine then why don't we put you
in this suit I was gonna suggest that if
you refused you go without me I need to
do this Simon this is important I need
to launch the arc you'd really do it
change body yes if you want to see here
I'm not gonna stand in your way I don't
want to tell you what to do won't be
like before close my eyes and then and
then open though again all right let's
do it
thank you go sit in the pilot's seat in
the next room you might need to boot it
up now this is gonna be weird what if it
leaves a copy behind is it is it gonna
be like that is it gonna make a scan or
is it just gonna transfer over whoa do I
need to do anything when you look back
the activity manifested by your cortex
chip run it through the amplifier feed
it into the new chip and then make sure
it's safe
you don't really need to understand it
just make them line up Dibby Dibby okay
can't offset that anymore need a little
higher amplitude that's too high
frequencies too fast offset go almost oh
we're so close just a little higher
amplitude up there we go everything you
can climb it to the pilot seat yeah
that's now amazing science control so
please
yay science hey the last time this
happened I was in the evil within
what have you picture vision camera
world you know Indian stuff photos with
stealers so that's what I said in the
beginning of the game okay whoa hey
there how do you hey ho neighbor I knew
it I knew it
oh no me no why was it still talking
it's the same before Catherine why was
he still talking
that's how horse you know that what do
you mean you know it's not magic you
will call me the sleeping sign under the
seat was copied and now you are here
just like Simon lived on in Toronto
god damn you cat - Simon's there can't
be - Simon's what did you think what
happened that you're gonna take my mind
and put it into another body like a
brain transplant I'm sorry it wouldn't
work that way you realized how messed up
this is please I didn't mean to upset
how did you expect me to react to this
[ __ ] please stop you're [ __ ]
disgusting what's gonna happen to him
he'll sleep for a while a few days and
then what wake up in his [ __ ]
nightmare again all alone so cruel well
what do you want me to do it him make
friends let him know that we have to
leave him behind when we go into the
abyss what if what if he didn't need to
wake up you do with that no no
maybe there I set it up for you hits a
switch if you want to drain this battery
he'll die within a minute I'd rather not
stay plugged in any longer holy crap I
knew that was I had a fight a sneaking
suspicion that was gonna happen and now
like it forced me to be in the ethical
dilemma of do I kill what was just me a
few seconds ago what in the world look
if you guys have ever seen that movie uh
I forget the name of it the prestige I
believe it was yeah like and spoiler
alert but like a big part of that was
this magic trick that was involved magic
by science built by Tesla and all
pseudoscience of course but it made
copies and what are you like you should
watch that movie watch that movie I'll
try not to spoil it if you haven't seen
the prestige go watch it it's not the
best movie but it does have some really
interesting things but now this like
this reaches a whole new level of weird
just because that was me
and the game is putting it in a
different perspective because the game
is translating into instead of me
staying in the suit and obviously the
game ends and then the other character
goes on it's it's forcing me the
perspective that I moved from that suit
and then my consciousness continues from
that point but the ethics of it is
different because it's not necessarily
it's a continuation for the person in
the new suit it's not a continuation for
this Simon right in front of me how
messed up is that
seriously how messed up is that
man that's so bizarre to be perfectly
honest there's two options here I could
end Simon here because it would seem
that his existence would be hopeless
considering that he'd be trapped he'd
down here but my other thought processes
and I don't know how correct this is
with in relation to the game if he's
still alive and he wakes up a few days
later then he might still be able to
help and do something and then go on
about because going into the abyss might
be a suicide mission
there would be no Simon I mean just
coming here and then being locked in
this room alone would be a pretty
terrible fate but at the same time it
could also mean that we get help further
on it's hard to say what's the right
option here I mean it down to an ethic
standpoint it all comes down to the
question do I believe this action would
kill a person in this in this moment in
this time and is that is that mercy is
is that mercy for what it is like how
shocked would you be to be to wake up
alone
but then again that's kind of the way I
woke up in this game originally I didn't
have anyone to talk about but the only
thing is that in his mind he knows that
he might have been abandoned oh man
so hard such a choice oh god what would
I do
would I do all ethical dilemma aside
mime in my mind it's a weird logic thing
but there's use for him to be alive I
don't know how he's he did me but not me
the character and the guy I don't know
how me the old me in the character game
is gonna respond to waking up and being
abandoned but considering his already
will to survive I'm thinking that maybe
he would you know so me personally I
feel like there's still use for that
Simon to be alive as weird as it is to
have two copies around and how bizarre
that is okay I can't pull that plug not
just for the sake of its really bizarre
but for the sake of could could mean
something later that's the choice I'm
making as the choice I gotta make I got
I gotta make my choices I gotta stick
with him oh man
not so weird so weird
god is so weird
I'm still picturing that at the end of
this game that probably is only one
ending considering you know frictional
games but it's still it's really
interesting to think that these choices
could impact why does everything look
like eyes that's got to be intentional
symbolism here everything looks like red
glowy eyes okay
so what do we got here got a bunch of
the scaffolding I don't know if I was
supposed to go this way but seemed like
the out-of-the-way path which I want to
explore first that's not a good sound oh
boy yeah all right so there's a way down
there
but I don't know if one's the right and
one's the wrong way let me go over that
way first because maybe it was
presenting me with the secret path right
off the bat that's so weird like I like
when I come up to these choices I can
only make the choices that feel right in
my heart and in that instance like it's
such a bizarre situation because I have
the benefit of continuation like the
Simon that I'm in right now has the
benefit of moving forward so of course
he would feel more privileged to live
Simon's life than the other one but at
the same time at that very instance it's
like they become twins like instantly
they become twins and when twins are
born they're genetically identical and I
guess when twins are born they have the
same memories and experiences that
before but it's the Missy experiences
afterwards that shape the person who
they are so all things considered as
bizarre as it is that Simon's like my
brother now in a weird way so yeah there
you have it hello yeah
I think I didn't I didn't do a thing
I mean I yelled at you I was really mad
but you can you can you know you can you
can expect that oh hey oh I thought you
were bubble butt oh man okay
passengers one a CR D send her wing Bing
should I sit ah
what I didn't I don't get the seat with
the lackey loo oh okay it's like a
roller coaster this is gonna be fun on a
bun oh wow
that is a long way to gone right I woke
up in the right body is redundant coffee
will never experience my attorney the
full journey you wouldn't understand how
could he
I couldn't do it and you knew it
you were right in trying to hide only
push you've done a better job
it basically flipped a coin and if I had
called the wrong side I'd be rotting
away at Omicron I mean there's nowhere
to know right you didn't hit that make
sure Simon wakes up in the right bodies
which did you know that you would know I
mean he was still claim to be the right
son Christ this is awful we did an awful
[ __ ] thing and you wouldn't mind why
would you how did you know that it's not
me the me that I am the same that I've
always been please say something I don't
want to think please I don't know what
to say I don't want to upset you say
anything when I was little I used to
climb the stairs a little bit at the top
of the building and I can still feel how
I did it you know took my arm so he
pushed the heavy steel door open
oh the first time that I dared go up
there I stepped out onto the roof and
watched the Swan rise and fall over
Taipei got all the way up to the car
ledge and you know I felt a warm wind in
my hair and the Sun was setting the
streets below were shadowed by the tall
buildings the people pushing to the
craft like paint from an Orabrush Street
food vendors filled the air with aromas
of all my favorite foods
her boys moment I felt connected to the
world in a way that I had never had
before it was the most profound feeling
of comfort and sense of belonging I
could ever hope for
I really never felt the same way again
but I went up to the roof many times
after I'm not religious but I can see
why people would be the privilege of
being makes a strong case at least every
once in a while do you still feel that
sense of awe even like this things are
different but we're still here it's a
point of going on everyone's gone how
the people still left our digital copies
trapped in computers at the bottom of
the sea we'll never be able to rebuild
and reclaim what we were are you really
so unhappy being what you are
or is this about the man who went for a
scan 100 years ago oh I guess when I was
back in Toronto even the worst case the
darkest futures that could predict they
at least included my previous life
somehow I feel so imprudent there's
nothing here that I recognize nothing
that makes me feel like I belong even if
we make it to the heart would it be any
different I'd still be alone
no friends no family you can make new
friends I'm sure everyone would like to
know the time traveller if not you still
have oh boy
well I knew some was gonna interrupt
this beautiful moment this is gonna be
the done bath
hello Catherine what happened oh oh you
have to wait till the next episode to
find out boy do I love a good
cliffhanger who knows what's gonna
happen in the next episode ponder your
thoughts about the duplicity of reality
for poor Simon here in the comment below
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye oh that's a lie that was a lie
we have the biggest pig your thank you
my tie ow